il faut aussi examiner les autres
éléments monopolistique
alors il y en a deux autres éléments
monopolistique il ya la puissance d'un
groupe lui-même
on a vu par exemple que le groupe gbh le
groupe de bernard alioth souhaite
acquérir la sphère vindémia casino fnac
donc là dedans on a 800 je rappelle 30
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
nous savons aujourd'hui des grandes
discussions se font avec l'autorité de
la concurrence en général ce qui se fait
c'est que l'autorité de la concurrence
dit écoutez c'est trop pour vous vous
peser déjà presque un milliard d'euros à
la réunion dont bon hockey pourront pour
en prendre mais moins que ça donc on
vous oblige à vendre une partie et on
vous dit sur les 830 millions d'euros
peut-être qu'on va vous autorise à ne
prendre que quelques magasins donc
peut-être à ne prendre que 200 300
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
mais quand on prend ces 200 à 300
supplémentaire on les rajouta une
situation que les une situation
quasiment intenable et cette situation
intenable que l'on va vivre bientôt à la
réunion cette situation là on la vit
déjà dans les antilles avec le même
groupe
bernard iott donc moi je ne suis pas
pressé de voir aujourd'hui les
réunionnais en situation d'avoir une
économie phagocyté par un seul groupe
alors je vais illustrer deux d'une autre
façon aujourd'hui à peu près 45 % des
voitures qui roulent à la réunion sont
vendus par le groupe d'un arrière 45%
des voitures qui roulent à la réunion
sont vendus par un seul opérateur
économique
est ce que vous pouvez penser une seule
seconde qu'il y aurait pas en france
métropolitaine une révolution si une
seule entité industrielle était capable
de vendre quasiment la moitié des
voitures est ce que vous imaginez un peu
ce que serait aujourd'hui la position
pitre à dominante de cet opérateur bon
écoutez franchement c'est une situation
des plus normales alors
la petitesse des territoires n'explique
pas tout parce que d'autres opérateurs
pourraient peut-être s'installer mais
quand tous les secteurs sont privés
rouillé intégralement verrouiller
l'accès d'un autre est quasiment
impossible
je vais vous parler de camions des
camions qui roulent à la réunion 70% des
camions fabrique le chiffre d'affaires
du groupe de bernard alioth et là on est
à la réunion
donc quand on nous explique aujourd'hui
qu'il faudrait en plus alors qu'ils sont
déjà très puissant à peu près à hauteur
de 350 millions d'euros dans la grande
distribution
quand on nous dit qu'il faudrait
peut-être leur doublé heureux de leur
leur impact
mais c'est insupportable je vais vous
alerter également sur d'autres points
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un centre
commercial qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
gros opérateur la grande distribution
c'est d'abord quelqu'un qui s'est assuré
de l'exclusivité des marques et lorsque
vous allez dans un supermarché il ya des
choses qui sont vendus ici sont des
marques et qui sont pas vendus là bas et
il ya un partage des mares or les gens
dans les territoires d'outre-mer
ce sont nos concitoyens nous avons une
égalité absolue les uns avec les autres
donc ils ont droit d'acheter tel ou tel
produit leurs enfants sont sensibles
comme nos enfants métropolitain à une
publicité qu'on peut trouver ici ou là
ils veulent avoir telle marque plutôt
que telle autre et c'est le jeu de la
concurrence
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des marques pour
qui un jeu de concurrence mais quand
vous avez un ou deux opérateurs qui
phagocyte la totalité des marques
ça veut dire que si vous aviez un autre
opérateur vous auriez quasiment plus les
marques disponibles donc ça c'est un
élément fondamental et quand je regarde
déjà nombre de marques qui sont dans la
main du groupe de bernard alioth rien
pour ça alors vous pourriez après ceux
qui vont vous installer mais si les gens
ont pris toutes les marques et s'ils
sont déjà les seuls capables d'exploiter
ses marques des produits que vous avez
envie d'aller acheter il faut aller les
acheter chez se payer ça c'est une
vision c'est une notion encore
insidieuse delà de la concurrence c'est
un peu là que ça se passe ensuite
lorsque vous avez compris comment ça
fonctionne vous êtes dans les emprises
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'une emprise
pourquoi je dis que et maintenant c'est
ma deuxième révélation
je conteste aujourd'hui ou non de
république développement outre-mer je
conteste la propriété commerciale que se
sont arrogé les propriétaires de centres
commerciaux tout centres commerciaux
confondus
je leur conteste la propriété
commerciale exclusive
parce que c'est bien de ça dont il
s'agit un centre commercial est une
emprise dans laquelle vous allez et tout
ce qui va se passer dans cette emprise
là sera régi sous les fourches caudines
du propriétaire de cette de ce lieu donc
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'ils
captent à son seul profit
il va capter à son seul profit toute la
clientèle qui va venir ici alors s'il
avait payé pour ça intégralement je vous
dirai à tous c'est de bonne guerre
tout le problème c'est que nous estimons
chez république et développement autre
mère qui l'a pas payé pour ça pourquoi
parce que pour installer un centre
commercial il faut qu'ils les clients
alors les clients vont tenir
on va parler la vue font office c'est à
dire des marques qu'on va voir on va
voir par exemple centre commercial jumbo
dia cotée d'ailleurs à d'autres magasins
tous ses magasins qui sont là sont des
magasins coopté par le navire amiral par
celui qui a le plus gros magasin
donc ils le font soit dans ce qu'on
appelle un groupement d'intérêt
économique formel donc là y'a des
documents soit un groupement d'intérêt
économique informelle parce que ces gens
là travaillent tout le temps semblait
depuis souvent de nombreuses années
qu'ils ont plus besoin nécessairement de
signer des papiers entre eux mais ils
s'allient en permanence ça n'est pas
aujourd'hui féret jure à ces entreprises
là que de le dire
il suffit d'ouvrir les yeux et de
s'apercevoir que c'est tout le temps
qu'a c'est la répétitivité d'un cd or ce
qui se passe aussi en métropole
la différence c'est qu'en métropole il
ya une vraie concurrence parce que les
territoires sont assez grands pour qu'on
puisse avoir des vrais concurrence
là-bas la petitesse des territoires
fait qu'on peut pas de faire cette
position dominante qu'il ondes de cette
position qui a consisté à capter la
clientèle
elle est obtenue pour par deux grands
facteurs le premier c'est la
surrémunération car c'est bel et bien
sûr la surrémunération avec le fait que
des gens ont des pouvoirs d'achat qui
sont très élevés que ces grands groupes
industriels se sont se sont installés et
à n'en point douter les prix que vous
avez aujourd'hui sont calculés pour les
gens qui sont sur rémunérés et pas pour
ceux qui ne le sont pas donc on va nous
essayer de voir pourquoi et comment on
peut obtenir une descente significative
des prix donc la surrémunération et donc
la pompe la pompe argent principal qui a
permis à ces grands groupes industriels
de s'installer
le deuxième point c'est les
infrastructures routières
on l'a vu c'est le tout voiture dans les
territoires c'est le tout voiture
donc les gens doivent d'y aller quand il
faut aller un supermarché il faut
emprunter des routes
quant à des promotions il faut mettre
les fortes lors de heurts au rond point
tout ça c'est encore de l'argent public
deux fois l'argent public
surrémunération argent public
infrastructures routières jean plupart
me dit bon oui mais on paye des impôts
pour ça certes vous payez des impôts et
pas à due concurrence des
investissements publics en la matière
donc ça répit écoutez c'est quand même
l'argent public qui vous a permis
d'exister par conséquent je vous
conteste lui ni propriété de la
clientèle qui hélas elle ne vous
appartient pas le flux de clientèle qui
vient là vous ne pouvez pas le capteur
votre seul profit parce que l'état le la
poche du contribuable a payé largement
pour vous permettre d'avoir ces emprises
dont vous avez fait aujourd'hui des
éléments captifs le deuxième point c'est
encore un point on va regarder sans vous
allez voir c'est très intéressant c'est
la verticalité
donc là on va parler des filières quand
vous êtes dans les filières en la femme
je prends un exemple l'exemple des
yaourts par exemple ont dû dire oui mais
les yaourts allez hop à la réunion ils
sont fabriqués elle a une envie dire
locale
ah oui filière locale alors quand ce
sont des yaourts qui sont fabriqués
localement propre par exemple la marque
danone fabriqué par le groupe de bernard
alioth ses yaourts qui sont là quand je
vais moins d'un supermarché je les
trouve des étalages très généreux à
hauteur des yeux enfin bon c'est
merveilleux quand je prends un héros qui
n'est pas fabriqué par le groupe bernard
hayot fabriqué par un autre général
il a deux mètres de linéaire et s'il
faut se baisser un peu pour aller
chercher les normes dit oui mais vous
comprenez ils ont une bien moins grande
ah oui on comprend si vous n'êtes pas
vendu à armes égales avec ceux qui sont
les eaux entre guillemets maison va vous
risquez pas de développer vos gammes
première chose mais ça sait c'est qu'un
tout petit morceau je vais dérouler le
fil avec vous allez voir pour fabriquer
les yaourts on dit ah bah écoute et
fabriquer des yaourts à la réunion aux
antilles ou dans nos autres territoires
d'outre-mer ça coûte infiniment plus
cher parce qu'on n'a pas la surface
nécessaire on n'a pas la clientèle on
comprend bien on est aujourd'hui guyane
réunion guyane partons
les antilles à peu près un million
d'habitants 1 puis c'est un peu moins
d'un million d'habitants pour pour la
réunion des bons donc là on comprend
bien qui a pas le marché en dizaines de
millions d'habitants qu'on va trouver en
métropole donc dans sa grande faveur
l'état français qui est évidemment l'un
des membres moteur de l'europe à dans le
traité de l'europe a prévu à l'article
349 une capacité à aider les productions
locales à travers des fonds là je vise
le fond possible
donc nous font peau cic quoi c'est de
l'argent qui est donnée pour chaque kilo
de produit pour dire comme vous
produisez des lions dans une situation
qui n'est pas égal en terme de en termes
de capacité de production avec ce qu'on
peut travailler en masse on va vous
compensez sont des fonds de compensation
d'accord donc là fonds publics
encore une fois parce que soyons clair
quand on parle de son européen on est
bien en train de parler de la poche du
contribuable français qui crée fabrique
de l'argent avec ses impôts qui envoie
ça l'europe et l'europe le restitue dont
c'est bien notre argent d'accord donc là
ils ont à cet endroit des fonds publics
ensuite on va retrouver des fonds
publics à plusieurs niveaux on va voir
ce qu'on appelle les fonds structurels
européens
de quoi s'agit-il les fonds structurels
européens ont la part des déchets verts
des faits à des rafah tous ces
dispositifs la ces dispositifs
ils permettent d'une part d'amener
beaucoup d'argent pour construire des
infrastructures et également pour
investir dans le matériel
donc là encore on se retrouve avec de
l'argent public
lorsque parce qu'encore une fois quand
on actionne un feder a fait des roues
qu'on actionne humaine en général des
fonds structurels
c'est bien des subventions dont on est
en train de parler on n'est pas en train
de parler de près on est en train de
parler d'argent que le contribuable va
donner à ces entreprises là pour qu'elle
puisse avoir un investissement un peu
réduit pour leur permettre de fabriquer
argent public
d'accord bon ensuite c'est pas fini il
ya un dispositif qui est un dispositif
mérieux en france
c'est la défiscalisation la
défiscalisation qui vous permet dans
certains cas de toucher un chèque à une
hauteur qui est une auteure souvent
significative et qui vous permet encore
une fois de ne pas payer la totalité de
la valeur des choses que vous achetez
parce que l'argent public encore une
fois elle a donc vous êtes en train de
vous rendre compte que finalement ce
qu'ils détiennent
tout à l'heure je les dis la
commercialité des lieux sont souvent
ceux qui détiennent pas toujours mais
souvent ceux qui détiennent les filières
verticale et là regardez tout l'argent
public qui est donné oui donc si on veut
s'intéresser à la cherté de la vie et si
on veut faire divisé de diminuer les
prix la seule solution c'est d'aller
chercher toutes les couches et d'aller
voir de partout à tous les niveaux
combien chacun gagne parce que à la fin
dans certains cas ça retombe dans le
même porte monnaie il ya une
organisation merveilleuse qui s'appelle
le rodobe leur dogme est un outil au
service largement du groupe de bernard
iott mais d'autres il est pas con
service vient d'ailleurs sont des gens
dont le métier c'est des lobbyistes
alors ils passent leur temps ils dorment
sur le paillasson des députés bruxellois
c'est leur métier c'est très louable un
d'accord bon pourquoi pas pour essayer
de voir ce qu'ils peuvent gagner de
quelle façon ils peuvent encore obtenir
ici ou là un des fonds européens parce
qu'à chaque fois que les fonds européens
comme ce sont des entreprises
extrêmement compétentes
moi quand je vous parle des gens comme
gouverneur eliot très compétent les gens
à la tête de cette entreprise là ils
sont ultra compétents ils le sont en
croissance permanente
ils font des milliards d'euros annuels
de chiffre d'affaires des milliards
d'euros annuels de chiffre d'affaires et
il dégage les bénéfices qui sont des
bénéfices ma foi extrêmement confortable
donc ils sont très organisés pour ça
tout le problème
y at il quelque chose d'illégal dans
cette danse dans tout ce que je veux la
réponse est non il n'y a aucune égalité
est-ce que c'est moral la question peut
être posée
est-ce que ça convient à nos concitoyens
de territoires d'outre-mer la réponse
est clairement non
donc nous nous avons examiné chez les
reds sommes tous dispositifs en fait et
on s'est dit les raisonnablement qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire et je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui que nous sommes en mesure
clairement s'il y a la volonté politique
pour cela nous sommes en mesure de faire
baisser les prix de 20% des territoires
d'outre-mer c'est possible